trevor story if it is his final day in
iraqis uniform and he's not in the
starting lineup so maybe he gets a pinch
hit appearance later on he has certainly
left his mark
in this final game between the
diamondbacks and the colorado rockies
game 162 as we close out the season and
close out fan appreciation weekend here
at chase field
and your starting pitcher for the
diamondbacks today umberto mejia 24 year
old right-hander gets the ball for his
fifth start this year and there you see
the 0-3 record with a 7.64 he's looking
to just have a good solid start right
here to finish up the season for the
diamondbacks
to first base christian walker's there
and there's the first out the story
headed for free agency launchers on deck
this is pop straight up for dalton
varshall still carrying that mask around
and now he
tosses it aside
roger's inching off first there he goes
this is sky to left field for henry
ramos
and a good start for umberto mejia game
162 diamondbacks coming up for the
rockies a guy that i've been impressed
with how he's throwing the ball he's
played for every organization this year
uh it seems like in baseball but ashton
godeau when he's been called upon
to give the rockies multiple innings
he's been solid
rojas hits it right through that over
shift
and a good start for josh and the
diamondbacks
and that high fastballs popped up to
center field hillyard territory excuse
me dozen territory you'd have to really
overpay on the free agent market
dazza another chance in center you know
the rockies a couple of years ago runner
going throw to second right on the bag
out that's two good throws in this
series from dom nunez
who uh earlier in the year did not
have as many uh caught stealings but
he's finishing with a flurry we'll go to
the second school
in the big leagues he swings and lines
it into center field he'll have hit
number seven as a big leaguer rocky's
trying to get something going
speaking of homer's is on deck
somewhere
actually i know where he is because we
just saw him this morning he stopped by
spilly is smiling ear to ear
so it's the only time you bought first
and second so the sacrifice bond puts
runners at second and third for nunez
this ball is ripped to right extra bases
that's gonna drive in two
and heading to second with a two run
double is dom nunez
two nothing rockies
there's a base hit the other way around
third is nunez and he stops it was
bobbled throw to the plate not gonna get
him
and now moving up is rymel
nothing colorado
this actually could go down as two
errors on the subaru super mode first it
was the kick
and then the throw that comes in
scoots off the shoulder of dalton
varshall allowing
tapia to go to second base
strike three car rogers caught looking
he has got his second strikeout one out
to start the third inning
swinging a miss he had two strikeouts
and a one two three third
welker has time
and he recovers tags the bag in the
inning rojas walked he's left at first
base rocky's up three nothing going to
the fourth
and daniels could have a base hit the
left field
he aligned it over the leaping try of
the shortstop for domo
daniel barton is first at bat of the
year has a base hit
to right near the line and the dive
which may be of ill-advised calhoun
misses and bard he wanted a run
he's a pitcher he's used to running
triple for rogers four nothing colorado
they always say that that can be a no-no
laying out when you're going to the line
as opposed to the gap i guess there's no
overlap right you have somebody to back
you up on the subaru super bowl and it
really wasn't close by cole calallen the
3-2 pitch
on the way
at the feet of mccarthy who just gets
out of the way ball four
that one
bart uncorks a wild one mccarthy goes
into second yeah i think that was almost
behind him
mccarthy on the move hayes in there it
gets away from mcmahon diamondbacks get
on the board jake mccarthy there's that
speed
what a difference he can make
he got a great jump from second to head
over to third
he almost took like a walking lead off a
second base it's a stolen base for jake
the error gives the run
and it's four to one
look at that ball didn't get that far
away from the third baseman mcmahon
island center
that one goes between hampson and welker
and van meters aboard
the pitchers will tell you who they like
throwing to too
hillyard won't get there drops in for
var show van meter had to hold up and he
just does make it in on a high throw
from the outfield
[Applause]
christian checks on the slider yes he
went says jeremy riggs and that ends the
inning
[Applause]
hit hard and down the line perdomo is at
it again that's a fair ball
it's in the corner and geraldo perdomo
has a two-out double
all right time run coming up it's rojas
peralta draws the walk
[Applause]
that's a base hits
here comes perdomo peralta stops at
second
joshua
the rbi it's a four to two ball game
[Applause]
oh he lined it right to welker
that might have scored him both instead
it's the final out and it stays four to
two tying runs aboard with one out henry
ramos is the hitter
bounce to first that gets throw
calhoun coming around third throws
offline it's a one-run ball game henry
ramos
and walker's in it third three-two on
the way
little tapper up the line
walkers across
and we're tied at four
van meters got the pop he can knock one
out of here
and meter fly ball
right field
hilliard at the wall that's gone
josh van meener walks off 20-21
and the diamondbacks beat colorado
[Applause]
you